LEVEL THAT WE D IT
TH A FEW HAVE TO KEU  MUCH ANME
Y RED THRLD.S IPLE COUNTRIES INN
, ISOT
SIGN.
KEY POINT TKEEP IND REMEMBER WN
EVIDENCE THAE DISEASE THANTHE .
BUT 'S UNLIKELY TOE TOTALLY  VAL
RESISTANT.
AYRESISTANT,
JUST LIKE OTHERIIK
REMEMBER THAT ONE, THEA VARIMD
ALHOCOE
SOLL KNOOUW
EFFECTIVE
WE CAN DO A TE
WHAT YOU CANO RE BOO TH EITHEY
FROM PATIENVE WHO
VE BIMMUNIZED AGINES, AND SEE IS
UTE OMICRON VARIANT.
WE'LL KNNEE ORN TH
NEXT TWO
IUNE RESPONSEO TAL OR LOOKIXA
INE, SEE FIGIT CROSS
NES OMICRON. KEY POINTE MOST IM
KNOW IS T
VARIN OFF IN THE THAAINSRIJOHAN
SUFFICIENT TO OUTCOMPE
DELTVA
AND I DON'T LYE HAVE
EVIDENCR THAT EITHE
EE NOW I
SSION L  A MORRMATIOI THINK NT
TO FOCUS O WE  K
RETHE UNITEDSTATES, AND THAT IT
S ACRA
D THE U.S.N ISN'T
ACCINATED.
>> WHAT ABOUT THESE TREL
REQUIRG VACCINATIONS TE?T, YOUHE
Y TESTING WHEN PFLINM ANOTHE
STING FROMOUTHAFRICA, SOE PRESUE
AS WE NONS NADEQ WORK THATUT
VE EFFVE
2020, D OUAVELINRL
FROM SOUTHERN EUPEO IGNITETHAT .
THANVEL BAE FOCUSING OURNEO VACO
THEY EMERGT OFARGE
VAULATIONS.
ALME OUT
UK I20UNVACCINATEDTIONDIA, 202
NOIC UAC
.T OPS, RGET ABOUT T,
LE THE
OP A EISVARIS
HS PER DAY.W BAD COUL GET IF ISM
HOSPITALIZATIONS, MORE PROBL
WIORE ANSMISSIBLE
AN ON?
>> WEL I THINK TS K
POINT HERE
OUR
N, WHILE THE
DELTA VARIANT IS DECIMATING OURO
P.
WE ONL 59% OF THU.
GOTTEN BOOSTERS,GO
WANI IY.
ACCINATEGOING  SUFIK
WH LS SINCE E SOUTH WHER HAD100C
INIOSED
E NOT CCEYAVINCOMPLETE PROTECTI
OTR AND E TO GET F  NOT ONLY WI
THE FROM DEA
VARIANT OR G
IT WILLIEX --
WELL. RESILIENCEAIOMICRON VA
HAVE TO ERVACCINATED INCLUDING .
>> ALL RIGHTDR. PETER TE
WEE
>> THANK YOU.
W HAD S WORST DAY IN
QUEST. THAN 900 POTS ITH"   MEAD
WILL DR WE'VE HING WD ABOUT?AGIR
BEENN THEND.
>>T BE CCE WARS IN
JIM.
MEAN IST'S
UNASHEN IT N FRIDAY
THE LEVEL OF UNCTY -U
HEARD PETER TALKINABITSTHE UNKN.
AND UNTIL THERE' O
CERTNTLONG AS TRAV
E ANOOS IF
RESTRICTIONS,
THAT WILL OWN ECONOM
ACTIVITYES
.
WI-- I'LGI
EXAMPLRE
OF GREATER, K  OMI DOE DOES BECT
PO, INCLUDING IN OUR , CNN,
S TOT IF
THIS WORSEG TO
THRI AT L.E U.S.COUNTRIEINSTITG
>>IGNOW, I PETEREZOUTHISYOU KNOV
WELL.
D RT
THIN WELL, FIR O
FLIGHT THAT CAMEM AFRICA
>> UNDEROFTERNATE
CANYOU, OW, I'0tR
ST FOR TRAL TING GALORE GOIN
N'AT
RSITALED.
DOING AND T EASIEST AND  OBVIO.
REICATED
RESPONSE IATE INN WITH O
NORMAL LIVES.
FOR INSTANCEE BRITISH
ANTIGEN, IT NOS TO BPCI CAN SEEE
RRT ONPARTURE. WAYN
IN IF YOLIKE.
LEDGEHAMMER
CRACTHE NUT.
AND WE'VRTED ON
EVYT
E YSAP OVEPENSIVE
T ABOUT IT, BUT HEYOIN OTHER
IF THE WORLD SHUTS DN AGAI
EXACBA ABSOLUTELY. ISH D
I DO NOT FORESEE CERTAIN UNITEDE
N'T STANR
EYOU I
SEE TARGETED INED M ING INTRUCC
THAT IS THNGER FOR DELTA, , STB.
RE
OSTERSAVA
RISK FOR SEHARM A.
TRH OF THE MATTE
FO THAT,THE --
PEOPLE AREYOU , M,
FRIENDS AND CONTACTS A --
PEOPLE ARE SAYING  ME, I'MWOOMRO
RRT OMICRO WELL T
YOU SHOULD BE MORE WORRIBOLEVEL
MANY OF THE COUNTRIES AT TAILURT